woe to those who call good evil and evil
good
and you're seeing it in the elementary
schools there was an elementary school
in wisconsin
which is now
investigating a school counselor
for quote-unquote immoral conduct
what was the immoral conduct
this counselor opposes
not just transgenderism
but opposes
transiting the kids
and this is considered immoral by the
school
melissa
darling received a letter from the
wisconsin department of public
instruction
uh april 29th warning her that her
state-issued license could be revoked if
the investigation finds she engaged in
immoral conduct at a rally they want to
determine uh whether she said f
transgenderism on video and whether she
said that she does not believe that
children should have access to cross-sex
hormones
or surgery
that's the immor i don't think the
immoral conduct is that she said the f
word i suspect every every teacher at
that school and every staff member at
that school has used the f word at some
point it's that she said i you do not
believe that children should be put on
cross-sex hormones and have their bodies
mutilated that's considered immoral
of course it is immoral to do that to
children it is moral not to do that to
children it's not there's no neutrality
here it's not just that they've said
look we're gonna we're gonna keep an
open mind and be very liberal no they
took the old standard which is
mutilating kids bodies and confusing
them sexually is wrong
and they've said no that's right
and not doing that is wrong disney plus
is doing this we will get to the mailbag
i'm always running late as per usual
disney plus
disney got dragged for promoting the
weird sex stuff with the little kids
disney right now
is doubling down on that and and
producing drag queen content for little
kids on disney plus
hello
and welcome to the disney plus this is
me pride celebration spectacular i'm
nina west and i'm here to guide you
through a magical musical and
meaningful celebration of the lgbtq plus
community glsen's mission is to create
safe and inclusive schools for lgbtq
plus students in grades k-12 and disney
plus is so proud to support this
wonderful organization for more
information visit www.glsen.org
[Music]
forward slash pride
what are you going to do about it
they've already been dragged through the
mud disney and they don't care they're
doubling down on trying to pervert the
kids they're doubling down on pushing
perverted sexual ideologies on little
kids
and they're saying this is totally
neutral this is look this is neutral
we're not pushing a moral view one way
or the other it's just this is open it's
liberal it's inclusive it's diverse how
cynical do you have to be to say that
sort of thing
woe to those who call good evil evil
good
if you
if you believe that there is no moral
component here if you believe that you
can just live in a totally neutral world
where the realities of right and wrong
and good and bad and
true and false don't matter
then you are as naive as can you you're
so naive you could believe gavin newsom
you're so naive that you could believe
joe biden and the rest of these people
who are pushing their radical moral
agenda
on you
and and for so long the conservatives
just roll over they don't even know that
it's happening right now go to
puretalk.com promo code knowles podcast
i absolutely love my pure talk i've got
my puretalk phone it is my favorite
phone service i've ever had i've used a
lot of the other guys but the problem is
verizon att t-mobile they're making it
clear that they care more about selling
wokeness than wireless
they're making you fund their agenda
with overpriced contracts and hidden
fees why are why are we giving these
people our money
when there's an alternative the
alternative is
pure talk just choose pure talk instead
just like daily wires offering
alternatives to woke entertainment media
puretalk is offering alternatives to
woke wireless networks the pure talk ceo
is a u.s veteran the service team is
located right here in america which is a
little touch that i love you never
compromise on service i was actually a
little curious i was a little skeptical
i said i don't know is this really going
to be the greatest network you know
unlimited talk unlimited text unlimited
data i'm skeptical i try out my pure
talk it's amazing just as great as the
other guys way way cheaper and and it's
a company that believes in your values
go to puretalk.com shop for the plan
that's right for you puretalk.com promo
code knowles podcast save fifty five
zero percent off your first month
knowles podcast canon wlas
p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com puretalk is simply smarter
wireless we also have my favorite time
of the week coming up the mailbag
sponsored by puretalk i love puretalk
because they have a great service and
they great phones and they're terrific
but even more than that somehow even
more than that i love pure talk because
they're sponsoring our new voicemail bag
so that you can send your voicemails
into the show and i get to hear your
dulcet tones go to puretalk.com enter
promo code noel's podcast to say 50 off
your first month let's get to the first
voicemail bag
hey michael my name is cooper i'm a huge
fan of the show i love what you guys do
at the daily wire
i want to ask you how do we as
conservatives deal with the crazy people
on their side my whole family is
conservative and
during 2020 they went off the deep end
with everything that happened you know
this coronavirus the the election
all of that it made them start to buy
into a lot of other conspiracy theories
that aren't true
for example my mother is a flat earther
now
none of my family members believe that
we landed on the moon other than me
they thought that trump was still in
control and like
he was running things from the shadows
or whatever if only but i've shown them
evidence to disprove their theories
and they just don't listen to it so
how can i bring them back from insanity
they don't even listen to the daily wire
anymore
because they think that you guys aren't
far right enough i hope to get a
response
and i hope you have a wonderful day man
thanks for what you do
even me i'm not far right enough i'm to
the right of genghis khan but okay so
first of all
the place to begin is politics is a team
sport
politics involves loyalty and you don't
need to
feel embarrassed of the p ever on every
team there's going to be some people who
are a little out there and a little
weird and we all have our foibles you
don't need to feel embarrassed of the
people on your side to try to score
points with the people on the other side
there is no conspiracy theory held by
anyone on the right that is crazier than
the conspiracy theories held by the
mainstream left namely babies aren't
babies and
and boys are actually secretly girls
okay those are the craziest conspiracy
theories i've ever heard they're crazier
than the flat earth they're crazier than
we didn't go to the moon they're crazier
than anything i've ever heard from the
right now some people on the right will
fall into things that are just not true
i i wish that trump were still running
the country he's obviously not
so i i would if you begin i think
you can begin from two places it's more
of an attitudinal question than it is
even a
substance question
if you begin from oh mom come on don't
say that you're going to make us all
look stupid to the libs and then they're
going to think we're crazy and i'm one
of the smart conservatives and don't say
that then she's going to recoil from you
and she's going to say well you're
probably in on the evil illuminati
freemason cabal too and so you know
you're
get out of here you
but if you come at it from hey mom look
yeah the libs are completely out of
their minds and they've lied to us about
everything and the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth these
days is about six to nine months so
that's true but you know the earth is
not flat actually and here's the
evidence for it and look but i wish
trump was still in charge but he's not
in charge and uh we can i don't try to
make him in charge again but
if you come at it from that perspective
if you if you think about politics more
as a distinction between your friends
and your allies and your enemies and
your opponents and you you realize that
that is just in a practical way that's
how you're going to begin the the art of
politics and that politics is not merely
loyalties and alliances but also has to
do with logic and has to do with reason
and has to do with objective truth but
you don't deny
the team sport aspect of it then i think
you're going to be more persuasive
so there are some conservatives who
their their first instinct is to throw
their own guys under the bus
and i just don't think that where i
think politically that's stupid and i i
don't think it's a particularly virtuous
way to conduct politics
so glad you liked that clip now bing
bang boom subscribe like ring the bell
do whatever you got to do subscribe to
the michael knowles show on youtube and
everywhere else we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]